[موسيقى]
-
دعم عسكري صيني يسول القطاع وتل ابيب تحقق
وتتوعد وبطريقه ملتويه الكيان يراوغ محكمه
العدل الدوليه اعضاء مجلس الحرب العبري
يكشفون نتائج المعارك حتى الان هجوم
الماني فرنسي ضد الكيان والحوثيون يحضرون
صواريخهم لمهاجمه المنظمين للتحالف الدولي
في البحر الاحمر الرئيس التركي يضع عرضا
مغريا بين يدي زيلنسكي لانهاء الحرب
والعروض لا تتوقف لياتي عرض اخر مثير
للاهتمام من الرئيس الشيشاني للمخابرات
الامريكيه وخيبه امل اوكرانيه تاتي من
الدنمارك وتشيك تعلن بد انهيار
اوكرانيا ضربه
لبنانيه الى جانب ضربات القطاع جاءت ضربه
صاروخيه جديده لكن هذه المره من لبنان حيث
كانت مقاومه لبنان اعلنت قصف قاعده ميرون
العبريه للمراقبه الجويه ب 62 صاروخا في
اطار ما وصفته بالرد الالي على اغتيال
صالح العاروري ورفاقه واشارت المقاومه الى
ان قاعده ميرون تعتبر مركز الاداره
والمراقبه والتحكم الجوي الوحيد في الشمال
العبري وتشكل مركزا لعمليه التشويش
الالكتروني وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش
العبري قد قال انهم رصدوا اطلاق 40 صاروخا
من لبنان باتجاه منطقه جبل الجرمق في
الجليل الاعلى وذكرت القناه 12 العبريه ان
الصفار الانذار دوت في 994 بلده ومدينه
على الحدود مع لبنان واليكم المصدر اعلن
حزب الله قصف قاعده ميرون الاسرائيليه ب
62 صاروخا في اطار ما وصفه بالرد الاولي
على اغتيال نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس صالح العاروري ورفاقه في البحر
الاحمر كان الحوثيون اعلنوا ان اي دوله
تنضم الى التحالف الدولي برعايه الولايات
المتحده لضمان حريه الملاحه في البحر
الاحمر ستكون د لصواريخ بحسب تصريح لعضو
مجلس السياسي للحركه محمد علي الحوثي في
مقابله مع شبكه بي بي سي بالعوده الى
معارك القطاع قالت صحيفه التليغراف ان تل
ابيب تحقق في كيفيه وصول معدات صينيه
عاليه التقنيه الى الفصائل وسط مخاوف من
احتمال تورط بيكين بشكل مباشر ونقلت
الصحيفه عن مصدر استخباراتي عبري ان الجيش
عثر على كميات هائله من الاسلحه الصينيه
وان السؤال المطروح هو هل جاءت هذه
الاسلحه مباشره من الصين الى الفصائل هناك
قالت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا انه ليس من حق تل ابيب تحديد
مستقبل القطاع واكدت كولونا في تصريحات
صحفيه ان القطاع ارض فلسطينيه وشددت على
ضروره العوده الى مبادئ القانون الدولي
بهذا الشان واحترامها وانتقدت وزيره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الدعوات المناديه
بتهجير سكان القطاع ووصفتها بانها غير
مسؤوله وشددت كولونا على ضروره ان يكون
قطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه معا جزءا من
الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقبليه معبره عن
تاييد باريس لحل الدولتين للصراع
الفلسطيني العبري فيما دعت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انالينا بيربوك ت الابي الى
ضروره حمايه المدنيين في القطاع وشددت
بيربوك في مؤتمر صحفي على رفض بلادها
اعاده احتلال القطاع او طرد سكانه هذا
وكانت صحيفه عبريه نقلت عن اعضاء في
المجلس الوزاري المصغر قولهم ان الجيش لم
يحقق حتى الان اي هدف من اهداف الحرب في
القطاع وسط احتدام الخلاف الداخلي بتل
ابيب حول من يتحمل مسؤوليه الفشل الامني
والعسكري في مواجهه عمليه السابع من
اكتوبر من جانب اخر سربت وسائل اعلام
برقيه سريه عبريه موجهه لسفراء بالخارج
تشمل خطه ضغط دولي لافشال مساعي ملاحقتها
امام محكمه العدل الدوليه ولنضع المصدر
امامكم
[موسيقى]
بعيدا عن حرب القطاع ذكر موقع اكسيوس نقلا
عن مصادر ان التوترات في البيت الابيض
تتزايد بين السكرتيره الصحفيه كارين جان
بير ومنسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه جون
كوربي واوضح الموقع ان كلا من كوربي وجون
بير يواصلان العمل بانتظام حيث تركز
السكرتيره الصحفيه بشكل اكبر على السياسه
الداخليه بينما يركز منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بشكل اكبر على القضايا
الدوليه ولكن علاقتهما خلف الكواليس مليئه
بالتوترات
تازم
الوضع الوضع الاوكراني لا يخفى على احد
لكن تصر كياف ان تعلم الغرب باستمرار ما
يحدث حيث اشار القائد العام للقوات
الاوكرانيه فاليري زالو جيني خلال محادثه
هاتفيه مع قائد القوات المشتركه التابعه
لحلف الناتو في اوروبا كريستوفر كافولي
الى الوضع العملياتي الصعب للغايه على
الجبهه هل يقدم الناتو على خطوه جديده
بشان اوكرانيا ليعلن الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان خلال اتصال هاتفي على الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي استعداد
انقره للقيام بدور الوسيط واحتضان مفاوضات
لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا فيما اصابت
الدنمارك اوكرانيا بخيبه امل جديده حيث
افادت صحيفه بيرلين سكي نقلا عن وزاره
الدف فاع الدنماركيه بتاجيل الدنمارك
تزويد قواه كياف بمقاتلات اف 16 سته اشهر
وكانت الدنمارك وهولندا قد وافقت على
تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه
هناك افادت صحيفه ايدي ناس التشيكيه انه
بسبب نقص القوات وتعثر الدعم من الغرب
اصبح الوضع في اوكرانيا صعبا ويحاول
زيلينسكي التوصل الى حلول جديده ووفقا
للصحيفه فان موقف اوكرانيا الضعيف وتفوق
روسيا اصبح واضحين الان للجميع وهو الامر
الذي يناقشه ايضا خبراء من الولايات
المتحده لتفيد صحيفه دايلي اكسبريس
البريطانيه بانه على السياسيين في
الولايات المتحده يدركون انه من اجل تحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا لابد من تقسيم البلاد
واشارت الى انه قد تتخذ الولايات المتحده
مثل هذه الخطوه في تحد لرغبه زيلينسكي في
محاوله الاستيلاء على الاراضي التي خصرها
وها نحن نتصفح
[موسيقى]
المصدر
من جانب اخر اقترح رئيس جمهوريه الشيشان
الروسيه رمضان قديروف ان ترفع الولايات
المتحده العقوبات المفروضه على اقاربه
مقابل اطلاق سراح جنود اسرى من القوات
الاوكرانيه وذلك في مقابله مع ضابط
المخابرات الامريكي السابق سكوت ريتار
وكانت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز قد افادت نقلا
عن مسؤولين في البيت الابيض والبنتاجون ان
امريكا لن تتمكن من مواصله تزويد اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ الاعتراضيه لنظام باتريوت
المضاد للطائرات وميدانيا افاد المحلل
البريطاني الكساندر مير كوراس خلال مقابله
على قناه داني هايفونج على موقع يوتيوب ان
روسيا لم تضرب بعد اهدافا استراتيجيه على
القوات الاوكرانيه بواحد من اكثر صواريخها
تدميرا وهو تسيركون مضيفا وهو كما نعلم تم
البدء بالفعل في انتاجه بكميات كبيره هنا
افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الروسيه دمرت ست صواريخ
اوكران مضاده للسفن من طراز نبتون فوق
الجزء الشمالي الغربي من البحر الاسود
واعلنت الوزاره الروسيه القضاء على اكثر
من 530 عسكريا اوكرانيا واسقاط مروحيه مي
8 و29 مسيره اوكرانيه على مختلف المحاور
خلال 24
ساعه
خ